one of the most surprising insights from
Einstein is that time is not what we
intuitively think it is right most of us
have this sense that time for you is the
same as time for me in some sense
there's this cosmic clock that's out
there ticking second after second after
second dragging us all in exactly the
same way into the future
Einstein found that if you and I are
moving relative to each other however
our clocks don't take off time at the
same rate our watches if they were once
in sync if we're moving relative to each
other they fall out of synchronization
now what does that mean well that means
that what I consider to be happening
right now at a given moment from your
perspective that might be the past
or it might be the future what you
consider to be happening right now
to me that maybe the past or the future
now since your view of reality is every
bit as valid as my view of reality that
means you can't really say the past is
gone because that might be your now your
reality you can't really say the futures
yet to be maybe the future to me it
might be your now your reality at that
given moment so in a sense past present
and future are all equally real they all
exist they're all out there